welcome back to I need to add some
breaks to Ricky Martin the ride because
this thing is going to crash at some
point and yes it was quite naive to
think that it didn't have that much beat
that it would crash into the station and
kill people because it just might i
suppose but i don't know if i went to
closer i like there's so many people on
it well I'll just close in it do this
real quick okay go back I'm glad they
changed this system because it's quite
annoying and we're just going to add
some break like that over there and open
it again also what's with all the mown
grass over there ah stop doing that this
is why you need to assign them to not
mow grass because they're gonna do that
and not anything else and it's going to
be stupid and it's gonna be a bad time
so I'm I'm running out of money hmm and
there's loads of puke yeah that's what
you get when you start mowing the
[ __ ] grass nope head Yeah right so
where's the other handyman hmm it's not
like the place with all that vomit ok so
other than that the park looks fine and
dandy I wouldn't have the research Oh
twentieth of July wait yeah that's right
and it's the 19th right now okay so one
more day I hate all that moon grass it
actually looks pretty nice though but
the rest of the grass isn't moan so it
slows of puke steel roller coaster there
we go thank you very much build that ok
so do I have enough space ah do I really
give a [ __ ] I'm just going to build it
somewhere question is where hmm yeah I
don't really know what to do with this I
guess I'll just add it over here and
just do a very standard looping coaster
kind of layout naughty enough cash
ridiculous um yes more alone that's how
you solve cash problems you just learn
more at least that's where the American
stopped me okay so we go down over here
and
it's not even enough room I'll find then
I'll do it like that it looks pretty
cool okay so we go down like that and do
some shenanigans with looping zor
something with loop-de-loops we're going
to go upside down because that's what
makes a roller coaster good it's not a
good roller coaster if it doesn't go
upside down right okay so this is the
twisty bit hmm I actually don't really
know what to do with that the roller
coaster is kind of placed in the middle
of nowhere over here but i might just
build the park around this that should
work ok so this path can go there so i
do need to keep that area open well I
can always go down though I do get some
symmetrical stuff going then I'm not
sure if I want that um damn this is hard
yeah so what do I do with this
I am what a nice roller cook okay no I
should be distracted I am going to build
an amazing roller coaster except this
isn't that amazing it looks pretty
decent though but no it's not great I
can always just do this and that might
work but I could also just make a medium
curve like that and then do some [ __ ]
with it hmm it couldn't work I guess it
does hey let me see what I can do with
that not enough cash [ __ ] more loans
there we go see cash monument and cash
management is not that hard in this game
you just have to increase the loan now I
should beware to add some breaks in here
because otherwise we're gonna have
crushes and all that and this Hill
should be higher it's not too shabby I
mean this is certainly not the best
roller coaster I've ever made but it has
looping so it'll do okay remove the
[ __ ] trees and there's no space for
breaks yessir as we're just going to add
some very stupid breaks like that break
it and into the station because we need
two trains two chains two chains for
bracelets and yeah right entrance over
the earth and trains let me see their
entrance okay beautiful and this doesn't
make sense because people are gonna have
to walk all the way through the station
but I don't give a [ __ ] I mean I do want
the entrance over there for aesthetic
pleasures so yeah I'll just keep it
there
and there was still a lot of vomit on
the paths but I don't give a [ __ ] roller
coaster one that's not a very good name
is it six scores five got nut we're just
gonna keep but seven cars looks better
I'll just test it with seven cars okay
so about the kolos I'm just going to
make the trek red I suppose and the
spores are going to be no decent but
it's not really oh I was very ugly and I
just want to go with black yeah you see
you want something subtle but you do
want it to stand out but it also
shouldn't be too bright and weird okay
so for the cars I can make them purple
no that's fine this is not too good this
also looks pretty cool but this is
probably my favorite yeah and I'll make
that the front car is gonna be it's
gonna have a different color the front
car is gonna be um purple yeah that's
cool I always like changing the front
cars on this Costa type just looks cool
okay so it's pretty decent coaster this
the name of the coaster is going to be
um i have no no clue really it's going
to be a lady gaga the ride oh wait no no
no that's a bad idea no that is a good
idea okay lady gaga on the right number
lady girl sucks it's gonna be um now
this is going to be like let your take
on the right ok so our people can't oh
wait better idea this is Lady gaga there
we go perfect like sometimes you just
come up with the name and you're like
yeah that's a pretty good name but I
think I just came up with the naming
sometimes you just have that feeling of
this is perfect this is literally the
best I could do and that's exactly what
I have right now ah see gorgeous name
really fits it as well okay and the
trains are really long yeah this thing
is going to be a capacity monster trains
are too long from
I liking but sometimes you need to
choose realism over and well revenue
okay this look good I guess so this park
is pretty much a path fest at this point
but I guess that's also realistic and we
do still have that main kind of walkway
going here one mechanic is more than
enough but I might need another handyman
I don't know if I really do but it might
come in handy haha okay sorry oh when
one place this guy in the water okay no
over there it's so hard to resist the
urge to just place everyone in my Park
in the water somewhere yeah we do I do
with this coaster a defense thing needs
a fence or a hedge because hedges are
cooler they look cool very nice and
there are already people sitting in it
so um what are the people thinking of
lady gaga I am NOT going on I go what's
raining yeah I can understand that okay
so this is the longest hedge in the
world is this a strong going to be in
the Guinness Book of Records psych there
are amazes them I did not think about
that okay so this area needs some
shrubbery eat some bushes question is
which one ahh a squirrel or as the
germans would say a squirrel so very
nice is that no that's not right like
that but that's not know I want the
placement to be perfect and this is
perfect aha I like that some squirrels
okay and some of these bushes because I
haven't placed any of these yet but
they're pretty cool
and perhaps a very small tree or
something do we have some small trees
yeah we have this thing this thing is
cool yeah if it's it nice I like it and
of course we need some of these trees as
well hey stop that and what else I don't
know really just some simple furs and
not underneath the support though oh the
train is nearly full I'm very nice you
know you can say of lady gaga what you
want but she sure does make a lot of
money and some of this this is a red fur
this is a red fur oh and this is a
Caucasian about nola for how do I even
pronounce that why am I so terrible
english okay so um and this is a
beautiful common juniper professor
juniper damn it why why Pokemon why I
must be very honest I learned about the
names of many trees and flowers thanks
to the Pokemon games and roller coaster
I don't even have an ice cream shop yet
I'll at that at some point however I
still do want to expand on the park and
this coaster needs some grown foliage
yeah and of course the zip zapper is
broken down then why couldn't it break
down and then like speed up that's what
i like the most of them carousels
breaking down when they speed up and
then they reach ridiculous speeds and
all the guests die I mean it actually it
actually does happen minus the guests
dying part sadly dude out of the many
ways you can kill peeps in roller
coaster tycoon the best possible way was
if you could actually speed up a
carousel to kill people that would be so
amazing
okay so now this this beautiful little
path over here and need some trees very
nice very symmetrical I like it this
might be a bit too fancy actually
however I don't give it I'll just place
a tree over here nice tree and a little
fence explain the hell not that's the
biggest fence ever it's a it's its
purpose is to keep people away from this
tree it's a very very special and rare
kind of tree group wouldn't wait I don't
want that nobody wants that stop stop
breeze I stopped you I just saved myself
there we need more gentle rides and more
well thrill rides I mean this is a
shitty roller coaster nobody wants okay
so how much money is Lady Gaga making
two thousand and our that's barely
anything like Ricky Martin makes nine
thousand in your head it's terrible what
are the people thinking lady gaga oh
wait oh I can see it the price is way
too low of course how do I keep
forgetting we just resetting the prices
how do I even ladygaga was great yeah
she sure was but something happened I
guess Lady Gaga looks too intense for me
[ __ ] why 10 years I mean no not even 10
years I'm 18 years old I've been playing
this enzyme for that means 14 years of
renaming attractions to get some really
weird sentences and it's still fun how
do you do this rollercoaster tycoon
rollerCoaster Tycoon is pretty much like
George Clooney like the older it gets
the better it gets somehow okay now we
do need a ferris wheel simply because we
want people to get stuck in our ferris
wheel and they'll complain and haha I'll
be able to laugh hysterically and
they're there well pain and misery
inside the facts shut up okay
why don't go over there thank you and we
need a little Q over here the Q is not
going to be too big because otherwise
guests are going to complain you don't
want them guests complaining this feels
like the perfect spot for fountain so
fountain it is do unlike those colors of
the ferris wheel actually they're decent
but I feel like this perhaps and that
would be better though this is a very
weird shade of green um that's way too
light and that's way too subtle that's
way too dark ah dammit green fingers
still the best bet yeah this is just
going to be the ferris wheel there we go
Ferris Bueller no that's a terrible name
for a ferris wheel oh wait I have a
better idea where's my be ah there we go
yeah look at them people riding ladygaga
what a rough ride it is how it actually
is a rough ride it's pretty fast and how
did I not add a photo section over there
I easily could have done that oh well
whatever ok so the park looks pretty
swell and I do like the way it looks ok
so how many months do I have left Oh
September well a bit while the entire
month of October basically and a bit of
September what's the next ride going to
be unknown maximum funding I've plenty
of money actually I'm probably I
probably have the worst negative company
value I definitely do however I don't
care ok so I've placed all of these
things and what's left is ah me and this
log flume yeah or a boat hire well good
luck with that I know I once created a
pond to make a boat hire but the pond
just cost me more money than bowling a
roller coaster so that doesn't really
make
much sense somebody's igniting fireworks
outside shut up it's not the fourth of
July maybe an ice cream store doesn't
make too much sense either like I could
place it yeah let's just go for the
haunted house might as well like it's
stupid flat right nobody likes the
haunted house but you need to do
something right I mean economic crisis
and all that you need to do something
okay so we're going to place that there
we're gonna have that cue go through the
woods and all that very nice this is
just constantly building we need to stop
we never we never stop building that's
basically it don't stop building don't
start building because I'm having a good
time okay so open that haunted house oh
damn it i forgot now we're gonna have
the shitty annoying haunted house
[ __ ] sound effects life is gonna be
ten percent worse after this damn you
haunted house we will meet again don't
worry about that and some bushes very
nice and some of these what it is called
oh right three yeah I remember that one
oh yeah very nice very nice yeah very
nice treat basically Oh still needs more
on the side and that thing my trees over
here by the way ah that's good a bit
more I am afraid of the emptiness so I'm
just going to fill the emptiness with
trees I like this strange layout but it
works okay so what are we researching a
gentle ride that can be finished in
ninth October well that's still going to
take a while and nobody's riding lady
gaga I suppose that's because it's
raining Oh nobody even as thoughts about
Lady Gaga makes sense and Ricky Martin
is still going strong
you could say what you want but vdara
fever I was okay I was again about to
say viva viva la vida I can live in la
vida loca it sure is money maker no it
makes less money now hmm Martin the damn
it damn you Martin okay can't start
construction oh that's a good one oh
that's a good one I'm going to damn i'm
going to make a nicki manaj in one of my
neck spikes and then start construction
on Nicki Minaj okay yeah right that it's
kind of similar to pokemon as well I
remember everyone calling the metal pods
penis of course with us unoriginal and
all that and squirtle well squirtle of
course and then there's our book which
people would rename our penis and then
use gunshot good times hmm okay or just
naming any Pokemon who has the move
protect condom also works condom use
protects and um let's see I think I had
a Wi-Fi battle once why i use protects
to protect myself from a gunshot from an
eye Bock okay so what's with this what's
with this this why when is it the ninth
of october sixth only three days left
okay good come on hurry up come on Lady
Gaga put some pep in your step there she
goes
the great for lady gaga with many
interesting twists and turns the pike
does look pretty cool and it does sure
make a lot of noise okay so where am I
observation [ __ ] tower what months of
research and there's so many euros that
I've spent on it and you get the
shittiest ride in i I'm I'm I'm done I'm
done with this yeah sure you shut up I
am going to finish this scenario in this
episode so it's gonna be at this is that
the longest episode ever in gaming
history so what else are we gonna build
then I don't really have anything first
of all I'm going to say that you
shouldn't do anything because we're
probably not going to make it so it'd be
a waste of money to actually still spent
money on it what else do we have really
that's not too much I might build a
wooden roller coaster but I'm afraid
there's not really enough time for that
and all these things are shitty the car
ride yeah definitely I might build
observations out but if you do want to
build one it should be in the middle of
your bike and there's no room in the
middle might bike anymore so I'm not
going to do that and I'm not going to
overcrowd my park with stuff that I
don't want speaking of stuff that I
don't want i'm going to place benches I
need that it's not really something that
i don't want but whatever and this
little place needs some interesting
trees like that nice however I still do
want something over here maybe I could
maybe I could build a log flume I don't
know how my company value is doing like
my company value is minus four thousand
well whatever it's already down in
oblivion let me just see if I can build
a very short log flume over here just a
very simple one you know the drill go up
go
down and back into the station huh I
don't like the look of that though no I
don't want to ruin my park I might as
well leave this area empty that would
probably look better than actually
putting stuff in it but then I would
like to play some trees oh wait we don't
have those trees on this side whatever
whatever floats your boat goat okay us
us us us and them them them yeah but
we're all just ordinary men okay that
looks good ladygaga still hasn't been
fixed shut up lady gaga oh okay is that
noise I've as as gorgeous eight out of
eight oh damn it Oh God oh no oh no oh
no oh no I haven't changed this no wait
no wait number of rotations to am I too
late yeah everybody already wants to get
off great [ __ ] job okay and let's
look at the hornet house 240 well I've
done it I got everything I got everyone
stuck in the ferris wheel which they
don't want your horror swing your ship
speaking of ships the Pirate Bay seems
to be up now but there's a waving flag
is something it's very sketchy but
they're doing stuff so that's good don't
know why that off-topic update though
which probably not update anymore
because probably I'm gonna be me and
upload this a couple of days later and
what's with all this vomit yeah clean
the paths over here I should just assign
one of these guys actually stay over
here stay there you are not allowed to
leave this area because this area is
pretty much clean apparently I'm
apparently Ricky Martin makes everybody
puke so either that or it's the eye or
it's the zip zapper
yeah you merry go round I think it's a
time thing get to the merry-go-round
like everybody thinks everybody to think
it's all fun and games but really this
is a this is this is making everybody
vomit that's probably Ricky Martin but
yeah I can't blame the guests for
vomiting off to visiting know that thing
well insert pretty nice bike there's
actually some of my better for us fun to
use I think at least it's nicely spread
out like sometimes I start over here and
I'm like I'm gonna make the most
beautiful pike and then I just built two
flat whites and i'm working on a roller
coaster and then it's october year one
and then of course you can't continue
you have to be done when the dates do
that's just are the rules man and you
have to play by the rules okay finish
that ride slow piece of crap okay nice
and why can't i turn this rain off what
am I going to do what am I going to do
is it already October yes it's the 31st
of October yes it's my company valu-
very much okay yeah with the company
value of negative that but it was a
pretty good game so save it regardless
that was very good so that's it for this
episode ah I should have had balloon
stalls and people like that balloons go
and all that would have been good time
so that was the first scenario that was
pretty cool dude I'm gonna I'm gonna do
dynamite dooms right away so see you in
the next episode bye